what look up in the sky it's a bird well
a duck to be more specific and four
other great picks for you to check out
right now along with an animated comedy
from illumination about ducks looking
for a new adventure we've got the return
and end of the DCU an epic Space Opera
not named Star Wars an adaptation of a
famous book and Musical and a wrestling
biopic this is the beginning of your
journey toward five great options on
this week's what to watch but first hey
there I'm Nikki Novak here to let you
know that this illumination presents
migration themed episode is brought to
you by Jersey mik as you know packing up
the family and flying somewhere else to
start new might be pretty tough to do
just as the family of malards in the new
movie migration discover where's your
mother that is not your mother but you
know what you can do you can pack up the
family or just yourself no judgment here
leave at home and fly or drive or walk
safely to Jersey miks watching them
freshly prepare Subs right in front of
you will give you the kind of Freedom
you can only get when participating in
bird migration I'm assuming so what am I
saying I'm saying that I'm hungry and so
are you hungry for something fresh and
Jersey miks has got you covered sorry I
like to get a little bit philosophical
after eating a regular turkey and
provolone mics way add pickles double
the pickles try it sometime from the
same people that brought you the minions
illumination presents migration now open
wide in theaters a great movie for the
whole family now back to the show here
we go tale for the torion check Wing
deployment check let's
fly opening wide in theaters is
migration from the same people that
brought you the minions the first reason
to check out this animated comedy is
really a whole bunch of reasons all
rolled up in one as in the killer voice
cast that includes K nanani Aquafina
Elizabeth Banks and Keegan Michael Key
oh yeah and don't forget Danny DeVito
another reason to pack up the family for
this one or all your buddies there's no
judgment here is that while many of your
favorite animated movies have featured
all kinds of animals through the years
none of them are all about ducks or in
this case a family of mards trying to
convince their overprotective dad to
migrate from New England to Jamaica come
on dad thirdly migration was written by
Mike White whose name might sound
familiar as the Creator and writer of
the hit HBO series White Lotus and while
an animated family movie might not have
that much in common with an adult dark
comedy white has also written for more
family-friendly projects like the Emoji
Movie and School of Rock true king
builds Bridges
right true king builds
Bridges also washing up into theaters is
the long awaited sequel Aquaman and the
lost kingdom and that right there is the
first reason to see this one it's
finally arriving after the first one
came back in 2018 which by the way is
fresh on the Tomato Meter with a solid
audience score a second reason to
swimming of this one is that it's
marking the end of an era the dceu As We
Knew It with new bosses taking over in
2022 the likes of Henry caval and Ben
Affleck are no more and a new continuity
plan is being put into place while we
probably won't see Affleck or caval in
this film it is the final DCU
installment single tier the third reason
to find Aquaman in the lost kingdom is
that star Jason Mamoa got more involved
behind the scenes this time around
helping come up with the initial story
that director James Juan and writer
David Leslie Johnson McGoldrick then ran
with at a boy Jason what do you think
they
want everything making its premiere on
Netflix this week is Rebel Moon AKA
Rebel Moon part one a child of fire this
film kicks off what is supposed to be an
epic new Sci-Fi Space Opera franchise
Lookout Star Wars from Zack Snyder who
who directs and also created the story
for this that's the first reason to
venture up to this Moon the second is
that the Intriguing premise for this one
will help set the stage for the whole
franchise and that is a peaceful
settlement on a distant Moon becoming
threatened by a ruling Force while hope
is found in one mysterious villager the
third reason to put on your moon boots
is the ensemble cast led by sofhia
bhella it also includes names like
Charlie hunam gimon hansu Ray fiser
Jenna Malone and Anthony Hopkins yeah
you heard all that right I taught us
about a place called
Africa she say our Mama's come from
Queens over
there that means that
we royalty yet another option in
theaters this week hey it is the season
is the musical drama The Color Purple
the first reason to watch this one is
yes it is based on the famous novel and
Broadway musical that followed both of
which have been highly acclaimed and
Staples of pop culture for decades the
second reason to watch this one is its
various connections to the first film
adaptation that came out in 1985
directed by Steven Spielberg this time
around he and Quincy Jones served as
producers alongside the stage musicals
producers which includes Oprah Winfrey
who of course starred in that 85 film
love all that thirdly the film's cast is
led by star to Raji P Hensen who's being
joined by names like Cory Hawkins and
haly Bailey plus some actors from the
stage musical including American Idol
winner Fantasia burino in her film debut
Harry I want you to join your brothers
in the ring yes sir I love that
W now we all know Carrie's my favorite
then Kev then David then Mike but the
rankings can always change and finally
in theaters this week is a 24's the iron
claw this biographical Sports flick is
based on the life of pro wrestler Kevin
von Eric and the wrestling Dynasty that
was the von Eric family who were huge
literally and figuratively in the'80s
that's one reason to jump in the ring
with this one another is that it
features Zack Efron in the role of Kevin
and the dude completely transformed
himself for the role impressive and he's
join joined by people like Jeremy Allen
White Mara tney and Lily James among
others the third reason to get yourself
stuck in the iron claw is the talent
behind the camera It Was Written
produced and directed by Sha Durkin and
while you may not know the name after he
got his start in short films and music
videos his two other feature films
Martha Marcy May marleene and the nest
are both certified fresh he's got skills
and now you'll get to see for
yourself well there you have it five
glorious options to fill up your week
and weekend and don't forget to fill up
on Jersey mics before heading out it
makes the candy taste that much sweeter
once you're in the theater trust me be
sure to let us and your fellow viewers
know in the comments what you did check
out whether it was on this list or not
remember to check out Ron tomatoes.com
for the latest updates on scores and
reviews for everything mentioned as well
as the movie and TV World At Large
that's all for today fresh family until
next week stay
fresh